he's not a catfish you the real guy yeah
and I'm really excited for Mama Tina I'm
she deserves happiness she needs a
husband and that's awesome you know I
missing you my mom out because I'm the
first step dad - and so she says he's a
great guy and I'm grateful to mother
he's real
well something great comes out of it I'm
happy I know she was like telling me not
to say that while the cameras was going
- no but apparently they heard us
talking about it and I just want him to
know that she really thinks you're a
great guy please make sure that you make
it your business to take her out on a
nice date okay she needs to see you face
to face and she believes you're real I
on the other hand was thinking she was
getting catfished until now and I heard
that you are real so I'm happy to hear
that you're real
my reaction is that is Deena it needs to
find love real love I hope at social
media she's gonna realize I hope it's a
true love five years in contact with one
person Deena
paste I didn't do something maybe a cran
get a drawing yourself maybe a stick
figure it's like that's what you look
like you're so skinny and you've got a
big round face but you're cute
you know I would think well I I can't
wait to meet him you know what I'm gonna
make something I have none I'm gonna
offer a double date with my girlfriend
and Deena and her mystery man - man yeah
I think so well definitely we're hearing
that Nev from catfish has tracked him
down and they're gonna try and connect
them maybe even tonight okay what do you
think about that that's amazing go go
Deena that's great good good for her I'm
happy for her maybe she found true love
on the Internet
it's happened before it'll happen again
god bless she's a lot of fun tremendous
person one of the biggest lessons I
learned from your don't go by the paper
don't go by the tabloids meet the people
before he make an opinion of themselves
so she's an amazing person I hope that
he is real because after five years you
haven't met somebody usually it's not a
good sign so I'm hoping that he's real
and
he is that she should definitely meet
him in person with somebody don't go by
herself Dina is a great person and she's
definitely looking for love and she
deserves it I gotta say everybody
tonight has had the kindest things to
say about you everybody says they want
you to find happiness find love like you
left a big impression on this house I
think you left a big impression on
America you're gonna see a lot of stuff
when you walk out and I hope it all is
great for you and I hope life's great
for you okay
are you excited that America got to see
a different side of Dina and meet this
different D 9 20 19 year of Dina yeah
[Music]